SARA CARTER.
AND IN A MOMENT THE DOCTOR WILL
JOIN US.
WE’LL GET TO THE PRESIDENTS
DRAMATIC NEWS IN A MOMENT BUT
LET’S START TONIGHT BY
APPRECIATING THE HEROES OF THIS
CRISIS.
OF COURSE, THE NURSES AND
DOCTORS RISKING THEIR OWN HEALTH
TO PROTECT OURS BUT ALSO THE
HOSPITAL CLEANERS AND THE TRUCK
DRIVERS AND SHELF STACKERS, THEY
ARE THE ONES LITERALLY KEEPING
AMERICA GOING.
IT WAS ANOTHER WEEK WITH STRONG
ACTION BY THE PRESIDENT IN THE
WAR AGAINST CORONAVIRUS BUT JUST
TODAY, AS WE SAW, ANNOUNCING THE
EXTENSION OF THE SLOW THE SPREAD
GUIDELINES UNTIL APRIL 30
PUTTING TOGETHER THE BIGGEST AND
QUICKEST RESCUE PLAN FOR
WORKERS, FAMILIES AND SMALL
BUSINESSES IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
IT CUTS RED TAPE AND GETS A 15
MINUTE CORONAVIRUS TEST, FDA
APPROVED, DEPLOYING FEMA AND THE
ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS TO BUILD
A HOSPITAL IN NEW YORK IN ONE
WEEK WITH MANY MORE TO COME
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
IT INVOKES THE DEFENSE
PRODUCTION ACT TO GET THE
VENTILATORS OUR HOSPITALS NEED.
AMERICANS ARE RALLYING BEHIND
THIS LEADERSHIP, WHICH OF
COURSE, THE MEDIA HATES.
WE GET HEADLINES LIKE THIS -
STUNNING POLL FINDS 60% OF
AMERICANS APPROVE OF TRUMPS
CORONAVIRUS’ RESPONSE.
IT’S ONLY STUNNING IF YOU SEE
EVERYTHING, EVEN THIS NATIONAL
EMERGENCY TO THE THICK DISTORTED
LENS OF ANTI- TRUMP MEDIA.
HERE IS THE SAME WITH THE
PRESIDENT’S LEADERSHIP THIS WEEK
ON ENDING THE TOTAL SHUTDOWN OF
OUR ECONOMY AS WE PUT IT LAST
SUNDAY, FLATTEN THE CURVE, NOT
THE ECONOMY.
HERE IS THE PRESIDENT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: AMERICA WILL
AGAIN AND SOON BE OPEN FOR
BUSINESS, VERY SOON.
A LOT SOONER THAN THREE, FOUR
MONTHS AS SOMEBODY WAS
SUGGESTING, A LOT SOONER.
WE CANNOT LET THE CURE BE WORSE
THAN THE PROBLEM ITSELF.
STEVE: YOU WOULD THINK HE’D
ANNOUNCED A POLICY OF MASS
MURDER.
>> DONALD TRUMP ACTUALLY SAID
TODAY THAT IF YOU DO NOT GO BACK
TO WORK BY EASTER YOU WILL KILL
YOURSELF.
THAT IS WHAT HE SAID BUT THAT IS
WAY DONALD TRUMP ACTUALLY SEES
THIS SITUATION.
THAT IS THE WAY DONALD TRUMP
SEES YOU.
DONALD TRUMP DOES NOT BELIEVE
THAT LIFE IS WORTH LIVING IF YOU
LOSE MONEY.
STEVE: THAT IS SO DISGUSTING.
THESE PEOPLE ARE CONSUMED BY
HATRED OF TRUMP AND IN ANY CASE,
THE PRESIDENT DID NOT SAY GO
BACK TO WORK BY EASTER.
HE SAID HE WANTS TO SEE THE
COUNTRY BACK TO WORK AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE AND THAT IF EASTER WERE
POSSIBLE THAT WOULD BE GREAT BUT
IN THE EXACT SAME INTERVIEW HE
SAID HE WOULD REVIEW IT WITH HIS
TASK FORCE WHICH HE HAS AND THEY
ANNOUNCED THE OUTCOME TODAY, NOT
EASTER BUT APRIL 30, 2 AND HALF
WEEKS LATER PAID THE WAY THE
TRUMPETERS TALK THE PRESIDENT
WANTS TO OPEN UP AMERICA AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE MAKES HIM A
MONSTER.
DO NOT HEAR A PEEP OUT OF THEM
WHEN NEW YORK GOVERNOR ANDREW
CUOMO SAID THE SAME THING, WHEN
NEW YORK TIMES COLUMNIST TOM
FRIEDMAN, GREAT GURU OF THE
GLOBAL ELITE, SAID THE SAME
THING.
WHEN AN ACTUAL PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERT, EL PREVENTATIVE HEALTH
PROFESSOR DAVID KATZ SAID THE
SAME THING AND OR WHEN AN ACTUAL
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIAL, MEDICAL
DIRECTOR OF AMERICA COUNTY
ARIZONA SAID THE SAME THING.
I’VE NEVER SEEN SUCH SUPPORTS
FOR ANYTHING WE SAID ON THE SHOW
AS PER OUR MESSAGE LAST WEEK.
FLATTEN THE CURVE, NOT THE
ECONOMY.
BOTH PARTS OF THAT ARE VITAL.
FLATTEN THE CURVE SO OUR
HOSPITALS AREN’T OVERWHELMED BUT
DON’T FLATTEN AMERICA WORKERS
AND FAMILIES IN THE PROCESS.
THE PRESIDENT UNDERSTAND THIS
BECAUSE HE KNOWS WHO IS HURT BY
THE TOTAL SHUTDOWN.
NOT THE TV TALKING HEADS AND
BLUE JACKET TWITTER TROOPERS
WORKING IN THE KNOWLEDGE ECONOMY
BUT THE REAL BLUE-COLLAR WORKING
CLASS CONSTRUCTION WORKERS,
FACTORY WORKERS, RESTAURANT
WORKERS, RETAIL WORKERS OF THE
FAMILY WHO RELY ON THEM AND THE
COST OF A PROLONGED SHUTDOWN IS
NOT JUST ABOUT THE JOBS BUT
THEIR LIVES.
IN FACT, IT WILL LITERALLY TAKE
YEARS OFF THEIR LIVES.
POLICY CAN TAKE UP TO TEN YEARS
OFF SOMEONE’S LIFE IN AMERICA.
BETWEEN 2008-2010 EVERY 1%
INCREASE IN THE UNAPPOINTED RATE
WAS ACCOMPANIED BY ROUGHLY 1%
INCREASE IN THE SUICIDE RATE.
LAST WEEK DEVASTATING NUMBERS
THE EMPLOYMENT RATE HAS ALREADY
NEARLY DOUBLED TO 5.5% AND IF WE
CARRY ON WITH THIS TOTAL
SHUTDOWN SOME PREDICT WE WILL
SEE UNAPPOINTED RISE TO 30%.
YOU WOULD THINK THIS WAS ALL
ABSTRACT STATISTICS BUT LISTEN
TO THE MAYOR, THE SHERIFF OF
KNOX COUNTY, TENNESSEE THIS
WEEK.
>> OVER THE PAST 28 HOURS THAT
OFFICE HAS NOW EXAMINED NINE
SUSPECTED SUICIDES, EIGHT OF
WHICH ARE FROM KNOX COUNTY ALONE
ALONE.
FOR KNOX COUNTY THAT IS ALMOST
10% OF LAST YEAR’S TOTAL NUMBER
IN THE PAST TWO DAYS ALONE THAT
NUMBER IS UTTERLY SHOCKING AND
MAKES ME WONDER IS WHAT WE ARE
DOING NOW REALLY THE BEST
APPROACH.
HOW CAN WE RESPOND TO COVID-19
IN A WAY TO KEEP OUR ECONOMY
INTACT AND KEEPS PEOPLE EMPLOYED
AND EMPOWERS OUR PEOPLE WITH THE
FEELING OF HOPE AND OPTIMISM,
NOT DESPERATION AND DESPAIR.
STEVE: IT IS NOT JUST THE
CORONAVIRUS THAT KILLS PEOPLE.
POVERTY KILLS, DESPAIR KILLS AND
IF THIS TOTAL SHUTDOWN GOES ON
TOO LONG IT WILL KILL MORE
PEOPLE THAN CORONAVIRUS.
YOU JUST WON’T SEE THE NUMBERS
IN A NEAT LITTLE FOX ON CABLE
NEWS.
I’M SICK OF IRRESPONSIBLE IDIOTS
ON TV PRETENDING IT’S ALL
SIMPLE.
SAVE EVERY LIFE, IF YOU REALLY
WANT TO SAVE EVERY LIFE THEN
TAKE SERIOUSLY THE DEATH RATE
FROM THE TOTAL SHUTDOWN,
ACKNOWLEDGE THE
PAIN-AND-SUFFERING OF MILLIONS
OF STRUGGLING AMERICANS FOR WHO
THE PEOPLE ON TV SEEMED TO SHOW
NO UNDERSTANDING OR EMPATHY.
FLATTEN THE CURVE, NOT THE
ECONOMY, OBVIOUSLY DOES NOT MEAN
PRETEND THE VIRUS DOESN’T EXIST
AND LIFT ALL RESTRICTIONS
OVERNIGHT.
NO ONE IS SAYING AND IGNORE
PUBLIC HEALTH BUT WE ARE SAYING
THAT THE VIRUS AND THE SHUTDOWN
BOTH HEARD PUBLIC HEALTH SO WE
NEED TO BALANCE THE TWO.
HERE IS HOW.
IT’S A SIMPLE MESSAGE, OPEN
WHERE POSSIBLE, CLOSE WHERE
NECESSARY.
WE NOW HAVE A MONTH MORE TO SLOW
THE SPREAD SO LET’S MAKE IT
COUNT.
AS WE DO, LET’S PUSH THE PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS TO DEVELOP A
PLAN THAT IS MORE TARGETED IN
SURGICAL THAN A TOTAL SHUTDOWN.
WE HAVE THE DATA TO IDENTIFY THE
PEOPLE MOST AT RISK OF NEEDING
HOSPITAL TREATMENT, PROTECT THEM
AND IF YOU ARE OLDER WITH
SERIOUS UNDERLYING HEALTH
CONDITION YOU SHOULD STAY HOME,
COMPULSORY QUARANTINE, PROTECT
VULNERABLE PLACES AND ALL OUT
EFFORT TO HELP NEW YORK CITY,
NEW ORLEANS AND EMERGING
HOTSPOTS FOR THE EQUIPMENT AND
RESOURCES THEY NEED.
BUT ALSO PROTECT THE PLACES THAT
ARE RELATIVELY UNAFFECTED SO
THEY CAN OPEN UP.
A RURAL IDAHO COUNTY BECAME A
HOT SPOT BECAUSE WEALTHY
VISITORS FLEEING PLACES LIKE NEW
YORK AND SEATTLE AND THAT IS NOT
OKAY.
QUITE RIGHTLY THE WHITE HOUSE IS
NOW INCLUDED A TRAVEL ADVISORY
TO STOP THAT KIND OF SPREAD AND
HOPE WE SEE MORE.
EVEN DURING THE NEXT MONTH AND
CERTAINLY AFTERWARDS, THE RIGHT
STRATEGY TO REDUCE THE
CORONAVIRUS DEATH RATE AND THE
SHUTDOWN DEATH RATE IS OPEN
WHERE POSSIBLE, CLOSE WHERE
NECESSARY.
THAT WOULD MEAN KEEPING THE BAN
ON LARGE GATHERINGS BUT IT COULD
ALSO MEAN, FOR EXAMPLE, OPENING
UP WORKPLACES WITH TEMPERATURE
CHECKS FOR ALL WORKERS AND BY
THE WAY, THIS IS COMPLETELY IN
LINE WITH DR. FAUCI HAS SAID.
>> YOU FIND AFTER A PERIOD OF
TIME, THAT THERE ARE AREAS THAT
ARE VERY DIFFERENT FROM OTHER
AREAS OF THE COUNTRY AND YOU MAY
NOT WANT TO ESSENTIALLY TREATED
AS JUST ONE FORCE FOR THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY BUT LOOK AT FLEXIBILITY
IN DIFFERENT AREAS.
STEVE: FLEXIBILITY IN DIFFERENT
AREAS.
OPEN WHERE POSSIBLE, CLOSE WHERE
NECESSARY.
TO ENABLE THAT FOX ABILITY WE
WILL NEED TO CONTINUE THE RAPID
PROGRESS TESTING SO WE CAN
DECIDE PLACE BY PLACE WHERE IT
IS POSSIBLE TO OPEN UP AND WHERE
IT IS NECESSARY TO STAY CLOSED.
BUT THE VITAL THING THAT THE
PRESIDENT DID LAST WEEK WAS TO
CHANGE THE CONVERSATION FROM THE
DESPAIR OF INDEFINITE SHUTDOWN
TO THE HOPE OF CAREFUL REOPENING
BUT HE PUT A LIGHT AT THE END OF
THE TOMO.
SO, IN THIS EXTRA MONTH OF
SHUTDOWN LET’S COMMIT TO A NEW
PHASE IN THIS FIGHT, MORE
TARGETS, MORE SURGICAL, MORE
BALANCED, OPEN OR POSSIBLE,
CLOSE WHERE NECESSARY.